hey guys welcome to D LM model lifestyle
I'm Nikita Morris and I'm a Nissim from
where and today we're doing a video for
you guys on photo shoots EPS when
shooting with a fashion designer yeah
hope you enjoy mistakes by mistakes make
you strong so welcome back guys and
again we have the amazing and me
something great from the loin cloth and
ashes with us so a while back we did a
shoot to give a campaign shoot and we
did a catalog shoot together again for
you guys which you will get few snippets
in the video of and it's basically we
want to explain to you just how it is to
do your photo shoots with the fashion
designer
yeah works yeah a designer's point of
view photographers point of view so the
first thing for me is basically is the
lighting it's super super super
important but you only be able to get
the lighting and stuff readied and
correct if you get references and you do
a lot of pre-planning and communication
with your designer right Alyssa
absolutely I think giving a brief to a
photographer is really important so the
photographer knows what you want I think
opening having that open line of
communication
that's important yeah I think the best
way to work with a photographer is to
always be very clear about what you want
so how Nikita and I worked is I gave a
whole bunch of references in terms of
photography that I liked and goes to the
like color like treatment that I lied
and for her to kind of just look at it
and say okay this is what we are able to
do with the location that we are wanting
she should shoot under all if it's in
the studio for Nikita to know what she's
shooting I'm quite heavy print of my
brand is really heavy in print so that
kind of sometimes you would say it could
affect lights you know yeah what's also
important is she eats in locations that
you choose upon either shoots in studio
or you shoot on vacation self where
you've got it like nice scenery or my
surroundings or something so there it
will definitely different they're
lighting preferences as well as settings
on your camera because on location you
would preferably shoot with lesser
lights and also interior lots more than
natural and ambient light that you get
so you draw the sheet with let's say one
speed flashlights or flash or some
people even just use a reflector and
yeah you won't use a tripod the settings
on your camera shutter speed for example
be super low depending on the depth of
field you want to them set your aperture
eyes are always at Lerner's
either for location or in speedier but
yeah then Mysterio going to that you
have a lot more lights and that
specifically Syria depends on what the
client wants like if your fashion
designer sandy references that
super-bright look at where the shadows
for example are falling because that
feels no way to put the lighting in your
studio but most of the times when
shooting a catalogue online for a
fashion designer
you'll have you have majority of the
times to provide lighting so two lights
three lights even luckily Nikita and I
work really well we have a similar
language in a similar style and
approaching things so it made made look
quite easy so we shot a couple of times
but yeah we haven't really asked our
kind of we bounce of each other really
well and also to just have a good team I
mean she has amazing assistants I have
amazing team of makeup artists and
models so all in all it's it you need to
have a great team beforehand and while
you're shooting I think things kind of
flow into each other yeah yeah yeah if
you have good models you will shoot fast
they'll know what to do they'll also
have the feel I get the feel of the star
very quickly I think also
for the makeup cause it's a team right
so I think even for the makeup artist to
know whether it's the makeup is right
and the lighting is there's kind of a
lot of prep before shooting from a
designer specific perspective stylists
perspective makeup artist as well as the
photographer to just get it right so I
think the first kind of hour or a you
know the first bit of a shoot it's
always like fine-tuning and what is to
be shot yes because you what you'll
typically do is they'll do the makeup
and stuff and then you have to the model
or like even the makeup or - son son
just stand there you take a few shots
check the lighting but what also makes
it different is how the clothes look the
color they are if they're very like
natural earthy colors they use a little
bit of a different lighting maybe if
it's very bright patent colors like
aneesa's then it means you need to have
also for example a clear background so
not too busy background with busy
clothes but if the clothes are very
plain a busy background is fine so
you'll have someone stand there take a
few shots look at the lighting look at
the makeup then change the makeup change
the lighting if needed take a few shots
again until the client is happy right
yeah and I mean we change our focus - so
for us we usually like to take a full
shot in the beginning and then go for
close-ups because I'm
ecommerce I have my things online so if
for me it's very important to know that
I've got all my angles because I think
about my customer and what they will be
interested in and then I'll say - Nikita
okay focus on the pocket or the color or
whatever detail that is really great and
I also think with with shoots there's so
many things that can happen in one time
you can have your the beauty shots you
can have detail shots so you can have I
mean we can you can play around even
post-production so you need to know what
the deadline is in order to have a good
time management throughout the day for
the shoot some sheets will take three
hours like we did today yeah and some
sheets will take the whole day 15 hours
like the campaign she pleaded that was a
lot location shoots are always fun but I
mean if we go on location and we want
quite muted kind of treatment and almost
what do you want things that are very
cold it's almost like everyone looks
baked and beautiful like that is the
perfect time yes attack the shot that
looks absolutely fantastic yeah that's
usually when this just as the Sun sets
so as needs to see you rise with the Sun
you sit with the Sun yeah as much
natural light is really great I mean we
use what nature gives us is very
specifically need to know like I guess
I'll be starting at this time we're
ending at that time and try to try to
stick to that schedule yeah and then
while you're doing that
and that is that that's important is
taking breaks in between because I get
super long and the design that gets
tired the model gets signed the
photographer everybody and you can see
it on on frame you can see when someone
is like and they movement you can see
them using that energy so thank breaks
in between if it's a super long day two
three even maybe four breaks it doesn't
need to be like an hour or something
fifteen minutes just to be energized has
something to drink and then you get to
that and for me as a designer is really
important to have a good playlist oh
yeah I think people always laugh at this
but I think it's important to just have
a different kind of energy a puffle just
the people inside the shooting we've
we've done a video for you guys be sure
to check it out it's a model photo shoot
tips for photographers that you can go
and have a look at they explain all the
basics that's very important from a
photographer's point of view including
the music have your failures like to
just also and something that also suits
the maybe the genre or the style because
yeah does that helps all the personality
of the model oh yes yes like the one
that will show you also that we did
today yeah that was it was really good
generally I think with any shoot is just
to not take it so personally or so
seriously if there's ever
at time to be light hazardous when
you're shooting because everyone needs
to have a positive energy I think from
every years of shooting where it can't
be kind of stick you know just have fun
fun and I'm really not a serious person
I mean there needs to be a lot more too
and especially when you're shooting
after very long we etc you just need a
bit of lightning yeah
so guys all the equipment that we were
talking about and even some of the
product I'll put the links down in the
description for you to make it a bit
easier yeah and if you want to check out
some really cool new your African style
fashion go to www.captainrapps.com or
it'll be linked down below yeah a little
yes
thank you so much for watching guys if
you liked it give it a thumbs up comment
in the section below if you have any
comments or questions and subscribe to
make sure that you don't miss the next
video okay hey guys welcome to be out
hey guys welcome to designer
[Music]
you